la deuxième chose c'est que nous ne
voulons pas particulièrement au moment
de ce week-end qui peut être un peu long
les ponts de la semaine prochaine on
gage quelques doses que ce sont je le
redis ici par rapport aux polémiques ont
existé je veux saluer la mobilisation de
tous nos médecins des infirmières
pharmaciens et nos cellules qui mobilise
ses cendres à paris en région parisienne
n'y a pas eu de défilé toutes les doses
ont été utilisées dans les centres mais
grâce à cela on veut optimiser et être
sûrs que toutes les doses seront
pleinement utiliser donc à partir de
mercredi 12
mercredi 12 vous pourrez regarder la
veille sur le site et de pauline les
doses qui sont disponibles et cela quel
que soit votre ange et si il y à un
endroit où vous êtes des doses qui sont
disponibles le lendemain et donc des
rendez-vous qui ne sont pas pris ils
seront ouverts sans limite d'âge et donc
voyez c'est un dispositif un peu
exceptionnel qu'on va mettre en place
et là je le dis de la même manière ça ne
sert à rien d'aller solliciter avant
mercredi 12 mai à partir de mercredi 12
mai et bien chaque jour comme ça en fin
d'après midi on va permettre aux gens
d'aller chercher éventuellement des
rendez-vous disponible pour être sûr que
tous les rendez vous sont pris partout
sur le territoire en france et cette
fois ci sans limite d'âge que vous
puissiez avoir accès à ces rendez vous